to uh to help celebrate our 11 years of
shows at tbs we're putting together
montages of some of our
favorite show highlights we've had some
amazing guests on conan
um and here are just a few the whales
are breaching
oh yeah no they're not breaching though
are lunging if they were to breach
actually 40 of them would come out of
the water
this scene's intense right right right
we're having an intensity
now stay with me we're talking about
something and it's important it's really
important and it's important that you
feel the intensity in the eyes yeah it's
happening
okay now that's film and television okay
and i'll pan out
yeah and now we're gonna see theater
if i just keep talking to you you're
going to start crying at some point
okay i just think to myself my god home
depot how do you do this
how do you do this incredible thing you
give so much and you get so little in
return
i mean some people pay for stuff but
they really paying you enough for what
it's worth
they're not really paying you what you
really should have and i think that at
some point people should actually give
home depot what they're do because it's
not fair
it's a company it's in a company that
should be compensated
this is an honest goodness fan letter i
am writing to you because i have been
holed up
in my apartment for two days and nights
watching all seasons of your show
i am in love with it all what this is
all amounted to
is that right now i am fantasizing
about having sex with
aaron paul
yes and for you to be there watching
swear to god it's a true yeah what are
you doing in this scenario
it says i am not sure what your role
would be
he's giving you some leeway yeah yeah
it's up to you you'll figure it out did
you say he's giving me some leeway yeah
yeah
is it he or she it's a shame oh i
thought it was a he the whole time
if you picture the letter however you
want i'll picture it how i want it
since my ninth grandmother elizabeth
banks
she was a white woman and they think
from scotland
and she came over here as an indentured
servant and she got down with a slave
but because she was free the baby was
free
so because it's the condition of the
mother so our whole line
you know they were all you were all free
as far back as 16
50. free negroes yes so that explains
why i'm so uppity
you think norm mcdonald that in one
minute
you can display all of the talk show
skills and now here's
norm mcdonald
[Applause]
yeah howdy norm i understand that you
had a little trouble with your wife last
night dinner
uh she's a sassy sassy gal
and uh yeah and she's uh well let's get
to her first all right
please welcome comedy legend fred
willard
hey thanks for having me on i love your
show you'll be doing
[Applause]
[Applause]
now when you were in the hospital a lot
of family visit you there oh yeah my
family came everybody came
everybody showed up just to tell me they
loved me except for my grandmother she
was there but she
just like every other old black woman
all she care about is education
so i said grandma i made it
i'm alive she said good now you go back
get your ged
i said as a grandma i was on a dirty
rock she said if you had your ged you
would have been on 60 rock
you do jabba the hutt dying you can do
java the hutt dying yeah
yeah i want to hear dying taunton yeah
okay
i heard a rumor once i don't know if
it's true that that johnny carson had
not started the tonight show i don't
think he started
his tonight show until 1962 that he was
considered
possibly for the role of rob petry
that's what they tell me i don't think
he ever
auditioned or anything but they were
considering him thank god it turned out
the way it did because i would have been
rotten on the tonight
that job's easy
like i've lost my tail i've lost my tail
they can
they can put a man on the moon but they
cannot attach these things so that i'm
not
jackie chan i'm not uh i'm not i haven't
been i've been running around here
it's falling out
put it in your pocket yeah yeah yeah put
it in my pocket
catch a falling start and put it in my
pocket never let me go
i always have a tune up my sleeve too
what are you looking for
i want to call the police
[Music]
[Music]
can you still dance like that you still
got those dance moves i still get the
[Applause]
moves
[Applause]
so i wanted to go to indianapolis and
talk to the people there about how
excited they are to see madonna and all
the celebrities that were there for the
super bowl sir are you excited about
madonna
madonna yeah no absolutely no no she's
the halftime show
you're an open since you're excited
about madonna i'm so excited yes me too
can't wait to see what she has in store
be great yeah so you know where i can
get any coke
okay sorry
are the super bowl champs oh my god oh
[Applause]
hey did you see madonna no oh she was
amazing i was in the locker room
okay the league's to be fine like what
they would have to do
i was telling my buddy the other day
like what they would have to do to get
me to stop watching
you know i love football you watch the
commissioner could literally
punt a baby across this office
with his wingtips on i'm still gonna
watch on sunday
let's take a look at this clip uh
[Applause]
listen up conan i wasn't kidding about
shaving your beard okay
it's coming off essay i've been
practicing
all night i'm gonna be real
gentle
that was your face you're gonna feel the
sting of my blade on may 2nd
the razor sleeps for no one we are back
i'm sitting here with uh will ferrell
and uh there are some aspects of the
movie we haven't discussed would you
shut the [ __ ] up
shave that beer guys bring it out let's
go
let's go if you want a bib yes i'd like
a bib
we got the blue stuff you got the blue
stuff yeah okay you want a little hit of
that yeah
[Applause]
oh god
these are vintage 1970s playboys yeah
take a look in there
you're not going to find anything shaved
in there
oh yes oh god
i am rock hard right now
oh my god
it's better than that
[Applause]
i'll tell you what he's plugging
all right it